[Musique]
et la paix du seigneur soit tous mer
avec vous
la charité du christ recevez est partagé
mais impossible de commencer une journée
portes ouvertes sans la traditionnelle
messe le lien intergénérationnel est
l'une des thématiques abordées pendant
cette manifestation de l'ehpad de saint
pierre pendant la semaine
jamais sans leur chaise pliante les
gramounes du sud profite de ces deux
journées pour visiter cet établissement
de soins aux personnes âgées dépendantes
qui me paraît des fauteuils le bruit
doit avoir
[Musique]
lieu à bonn quand même
bien oui j'y reviens première fois bien
comment on trouve ben super la bonne
visite en mai merci aux joueurs
réunionnais s'ils n'étaient pas là nous
même ne serait pas là aujourd'hui savez
la mémoire pour nous tous et c'est grâce
à eux qu'on transmet les valeurs ici aux
jeunes à aux nouvelles générations je
pense que les jeunes pensent ils ont
quand même d'excellents contacts avec
avec les passagers avec leurs grands
parents sur les premières personnes avec
qui ils ont dédié à son milieu parce
qu'il est important de ne pas oublier ça
une inauguration avec plusieurs
partenaires qui accompagnent au
quotidien notre troisième jeunesse il a
plusieurs objectifs le premier ça va
être d'ouvrir l'établissement sur
l'extérieur pour que pour que les que le
public sache ce que ce qui peut se
passer dans l'établissement satam est
également aussi à notre équipe de se
souder autour d'un projet en
l'occurrence le village bleus et ça nous
permet de sortir de notre quotidien de
swing et de fédérer une équipe en sera
le département est une autre financière
principale c'est cette saison c'est pas
c'est pas seulement un financeur c'est
également aussi l'autre un partenaire
privilégié pour nous dans le sens où les
départements donc ses prérogatives de
gérer les personnes âgées
à travers ces actions obligatoire ou
facultative le département consacre près
de 160 millions d'euros afin d'aider au
vieillissement de la population entre
2010 et 2020 la population de plus de 75
ans aura été doublé les centenaires
comme ces personnes du sud devrait ainsi
être de plus en plus nombreux il appelle
les cra monde parce qu'à la réunion on
l'appelle les personnages et des crânes
pour tout puisse se reconnaître et
l'objectif donc de la mandature de ma
mandature c'est de faire en sorte que le
g on s'y retrouve bien chez nous
ensemble chez lui le bien vieillir chez
lui et ma priorité je me suis rendu
compte que tant les personnes âgées les
gramounes reste c'est chez eux entourés
de leur famille ils vieillissent mieux
dans de meilleures conditions par contre
je vous dirais que les ehpad ont toute
leur place parce que arrivé un moment
donné on ya de la dépendance et les faux
pour soulager les familles là il ya la
place les prades
la visite de l'établissement a permis de
palper ce cadre de vie
l'établissement accueille 90 personnes
dépendantes divisé en trois unités
ce temps de proximité entre les
professionnels et les usagers donne
ainsi que des réponses à ce public de
plus en plus nombreux
[Musique]
mais il est bien
de manger les bandes qui arrive en tête
toute l'europe est là pour parrainer des
nouvelles depuis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]